[Music]
[Applause]
been watching the golf channel
sent a note to rich lerner the host i
said brad faxon's killing it
he's doing great
rich lerner goes i know so i said to
fritzy reach out and see if brad will
join us he's uh working for the golf
channel during uh live from the pga
uh championship monday through wednesday
seven to nine eastern also working for
sky sports just to give you a little
backdrop he won on tour i think eight
times played on two ryder cup teams and
brad joins us now brad how are you
i'm doing great dan thanks for having me
on this is a real honor do you ever get
mistaken for tony hawk the skateboarder
that's the funniest question yes i was
actually in one of his stores in
california
and some guy came up to me he was kind
of walking in circles and i thought he
recognized me as a golfer and he goes
hey this is pretty cool you're in here
and i'm like well there's not many
golfers that skateboard he goes oh no no
i know who you really are it's cool that
you just hang out in your own store it's
pretty funny
do you skateboard
not at all oh
[Laughter]
all right the story line at the pga
championship is what
there's tremendous amounts of story
lines i mean the biggest one was a week
ago when phil mickelson the defending
champion
withdrew uh we covered a lot of that on
monday on uh live from
like you mentioned with rich lerner and
randall shambly and um but what's the
reason why brad i i don't know
why phil withdrew after saying that he
was going to play
well i'm not sure that he ever said he
was going to play dan he actually
committed to play in the event and he
gave him the pga championships a little
bit different than
most of the pga tour events the pga tour
events require
players to
enter or withdraw by friday before the
tournament the pga championship
uh entry form is way earlier and a month
ago i think he was undecided
he talked to the pg of america's ceo
seth wa and just i think his his
handlers did and said he's not ready to
play yet i think alan shipnuck's debut
with his book that came out yesterday
uh and the troubling news that billy
walters is going to come out with
another book i think is trying to
has kind of kept phil at bay
yeah i'm just i'm trying to understand
what choice phil has in this did he did
he had the choice to go to augusta or
not go did he have the choice if he
wanted to go to the pga championship or
not in europe well again uh the masters
organization or the tournament committee
there at augusta international is
different than the pga of america
different than the pga tour
my sources say that he was um
requested that to keep his troubles at
home and not come there and make that a
distraction i can't confirm that with
certainty but i've had a number of
people tell me that
so
i think that phil is really trying to
get his life back together
yeah this other book that's going to
come out
i mean the allen shipnuck book is one
thing the other book
uh from what i hear uh it's gonna be
pretty damaging for phil i think it's
gonna be damning for phil and maybe tell
us a few things we don't know
billy walters uh went to prison really
um for the insider trading in the jimmy
dean sausage case and phil was involved
with that he paid back close to a
million dollars and
i think billy felt like if phil had
testified or come
before he
he might have saved some time
for billy walters
um
tiger's demeanor how would you explain
this this
demeanor with the media that's happened
it feels like overnight
it does feel like overnight that's the
first thing i was going to say dan i
mean after his accident he
spent
a year 406 days we know before after the
ad
like arnold palmer and jack nicklaus
when when they got
really beyond their competitive years
they started being
i think a little bit more emotional when
they played at augusta national they
were celebrated by the fans there the
patrons
um and i think for the first time in
tiger's life he showed some of that
emotion while he was still on the course
while he was competing
and and i think you know when you look
at this generation of the great players
now like rory mcilroy and jordan spieth
who tiger will play with tomorrow
morning when they tee off
here in tulsa i think 8 11 central time
um
tiger's been a mentor to those players
now he's invited them
to play practice rounds with him when he
might have done that alone i know rory
and tiger have practiced together
uh back in jupiter and he's you know
going to be a ryder cup captain when it
gets to beth page in a few years and i
think tiger has really kind of embraced
that a little bit like arnold and jack
did before him
we're talking to brad faxon he is
working for golf channel one two uh
eight times i got that right eight times
on the pga tour yes yes that's right i
got you best finish in a major was fifth
at the pj championship
that's correct yep i um i did that in
1995 i never did well in the u.s open uh
i played here in the pga
nick price won in 1994. uh
played in the us open here this is some
some course you got golf clubs behind
you you got what what do you have
putters i i have putters um i'm a
scottie cannon guys you probably know
but i'm gonna do a couple pieces for the
golf channel for later on tonight and uh
i have to hit some chips and putts
because this is a really damn this
course if you're a golf fan i know when
the players are going to miss a green
this week um
the course was renovated by gil hansen
one of the
best architects in the world right now
and when the players miss the ball is
going to run away from the green
it's going to go down these short moan
areas tightly known areas fairway height
and players are going to really have a
hard time
putting up these hills because it's it's
fairway height it's not like
tightly moaning like some fringes are so
the chipping is going to be a real
important part this week and i think
that players are really confident with a
short game you see these players
practicing
all the shots around the green i really
want to show the spectators what it's
like the viewers what it's like around
these screens how difficult it is but is
it like pinehurst
number two where you know you have those
greens that that are crowned and then
they just roll a little bit crowned um
and there's areas on
almost every green where if you miss it
short or to the side it could run off a
long way 20 or 30 yards but unlike at
piners where the the fairway cut around
the greens is so tight where it's easy
to just pick out potter and run it or
some players like to use a hybrid i
think you're going to see a lot more
players having to use a lofted club and
it seems like chipping has become an
epidemic uh worse than cobot around here
i don't mean it
um
it's weird to be covering a golf event
or watching the coverage and you talk
about tiger and we're talking about
tiger walking we're not talking about a
swing
we're talking about the comfort level
sort of the course topography here
what is different about tiger this
tournament as opposed to augusta
i think there's a few things first of
all augusta national may be
the most uh the hilliest course that has
the most topography of any course we
we play all year long
um it's not flat here in tulsa it there
is some topography here
but there's two big differences first of
all it's six weeks
from the master so he's he's been able
to you know progress and get stronger
we saw definite fatigue with tiger on
the weekend and augusta national i think
it was a miracle for a couple things
first of all a miracle that tiger played
the miracle that he smoked his first tee
shot down the middle
there that he shot a good first round
that he made the cut he grinded to make
the cut and then he finished 72 holes
and we we might have thought you know
407 days
earlier that he'd never played golf
again now we're
talking about winning a 16th major
championship um he's practicing a lot
back home at the medalist where he does
and he's been walking those rounds so
he's fitter
you look at his upper body now he looks
like he could play linebacker on on any
team he's incredible and one of the
things we showed last night dan
is his increase in swing speed you know
one of the things that players always
look at his swing speed with the driver
in particular and then that uh
the driver the ball speed at his ball
speed since he first came back to play
with his son charlie at the pnc uh
father
child tournament is he
really has increased his swing speed and
his ball speed and if you looked at the
tracers from his practice yesterday his
driver is going so so straight um i
think he's really going to contend and
interestingly in 2007 when he won the
last round he only hit three drivers
because he was so afraid to hit driver
and now he's really confident with
drivers so i think you're going to see
it at tiger woods it's really going to
be able to be in contention this week
you got a favorite john daly story
i i have a few um
i went to a restaurant in new york city
uh oh this is seven eight years ago with
all my family all my kids and i went to
a restaurant and they had a drink on the
menu called the john daly and
i asked that john the waiter who to me
and this is maybe biased he didn't look
like a golfer this waiter let me just
put this way i said who's john daly and
he goes he's a fat retired golfer and i
laughed i thought that was a funny
comment like you're laughing that's what
i did
my mistake was
i tweeted that and i thought it was
funny oh
and i got a call from the tour
and
john was very upset and i i had a nice
relationship with john but he had told
me his fans were upset that i did that
it was probably a mistake because
you know when you hear something and you
laugh it doesn't sound the same in print
um but that was a pretty bad move in my
heart i learned a lot then
uh good to talk to you i hope you're
having fun it certainly looks like it
and i've enjoyed the insight on uh golf
channel well dan i am having fun i will
tell you one thing that that
rich lerner and brandel shanley are the
most prepared two
uh golf analysts in the game without a
doubt rich writes all of his openings
everything that he says on camera he
does himself and there's nobody with a
mind in the golf world like brandel
shamley his he's got a brain like a
steel trap he remembers everything
everything
and i'm happy to sit next to them and i
love talking about golf i've been doing
it my whole life
thank you uh safe travels great to talk
to you again brad great to see you i
love listening to you thanks that's brad
faxon
pga golfer on time won eight times on
tour